in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week the prostate our topic
today and our expert in the studio today
is your honor is dr. code Villa from
here in Berlin dr. Miller welcome to in
good shape we just saw one method to
cure prostate enlargement but there are
other types of surgery yeah there's
still what we call a traditional type of
surgery with a electrical sling that
remove tissue open surgery has almost
completely faded away from from prostate
stage sort of and there's different
lasers that's what we do today mostly so
you always going through the erythro and
never in almost all cases we can operate
through the urethra right why is it
better than just doing an open surgery
well I put less strain on the patient as
if you do open surgery recovery is much
faster he's faster out of the hospital
less pain that's the adventures okay and
if you don't want to treat with surgery
I mean most of my patients don't want to
go through surgery can you use any
medication to get the prostate gland
smaller there is medication either to
reduce the symptoms that may be
associated with an enlarged prostate and
there's also medication that indeed
reduce the size of the prostate okay
North is available so so you can even do
nitrous sound and you can see that it
shrinks that's procedure entry yeah well
you cannot see how it shrinks but after
three months it may be smaller than when
you started the treatment so use a
urologist which you first try to use
medications and then perform surgery or
how do you decide what that's what's
really done in in most of the cases
unless you have a cute retention so
you're unable to empty your bladder you
would in almost all cases start with
medication see how the patient is doing
and then only if that does not work yeah
you would try to go to surgery and can
you take those those pills forever or
any side effects or dangerous this is
what our viewers so Gillette gava for
India wants to know yeah well it's not
you can
and take it for a long time forever if
you want some patients may experience
side effects and so they want to decide
to discontinue these medication and opt
for surgery but the initial usually the
side effects are not severe so yes most
of the patient can take it for a long
time okay when it comes to side effects
I always think about alternative
complementary medicine like natural
remedies are there any hand medications
you could use there is a huge numbers
particular in Germany many many
different of those drugs or compounds
are used problem isn't none of the
guidelines there is conclusive evidence
are reported that this really helps but
anyway I mean you don't have side
effects with these trucks usually and so
it's easy just to try and see if your
symptoms get better and are there any
dangers in not treating an enlarged
prostate gland our viewer Peter covered
from the Philippines and wants to know
as many of our you want to know if
there's a high risk of cancer developing
in the allowed enlarged prostate gland
no there's no risk there's no
correlation between enlarged prostate as
we call benign prostatic hyperplasia and
prostate cancer so so even if the gland
is big ever there's no risk and is it
more difficult to find a small amount of
cancer cells could be that you know in a
larger prostate biopsies by needle
biopsy is finding a small cancer may be
more difficult than the small prostate
yes I know the situation from my surgery
hours the patient's coming to me where
the urologist said you've got a tumor
and we just don't do anything about it
and they say wow I'm scared so is it
very dangerous to wait and see this but
one of you acquainted of it from Canada
wants to know if you do the right
patient selection obviously in we call
it low risk cancer it's not dangerous
these patients are in the regular
controls to look for progression but if
you look at the studies and we now
oversee these patients for time span of
10 years and more are only a very small
minority of the patients actually die
from prostate cancer during that time
even if you do nothing
and then what kind of patients are
eligible for this kind of procedure
others the more older patients it has
basically nothing to do with the age it
has more to do with the aggressiveness
of the tumor and we know there is as we
sail to move the very low potential for
progression and it depends on the
grading on the staging on the PSA and on
the palpation of the gland and that
gives you a picture where you say well
you risk is so low probably any
treatment would be over treatment in
that situation and so if you want to do
any treatment what kinds of options of
God well we still have the the standard
option for creating prostate cancer as
we call localized prostate cancer by it
either taking the prostate out the whole
prostate or radiating the whole prostate
we're now in the stage where we start
creating only part of the prostate we
call this focal therapy and we use
either heat or cold to treat particular
parts of the prostate which we now can
better see as in the past particularly
as we now have MRI more often used for
prostate cancer let's do some surgery
hours for prostate cancer we've got a
lot of questions here you just ask them
to you if you got a question from Zambia
Matthew Glynn wants to know there's the
PSA test we just heard about this in the
report so how a reliable indicator is
this test it's not a reliable indicator
for prostate cancer it gives you a risk
assessment and you may need more
parameters to see if the risk is high
enough to do further and invasive
diagnostics so in the hand of an expert
i think PSA is a good tool so as a
screening tool so you can go there to
the doc oh yeah it's a it'd be a good
early detection tool I would say yes if
you want to detect prostate cancer early
PSA is one way to go and you need it
okay our view of Vili kuda he's 85 years
old and he lives in Brazil and he told
us that his peers a value dropped to
number of two which is normal considered
was previously was higher after he drank
a lot of water 3.5 liters a day Z so
what's the relationship between drinking
water and the PSA test well usually
there's no relationship unless you will
say i dilute my blood in a way that you
know PSA goes
stone and by the way he is 85 years old
you mentioned yeah so I would have
advised him not to take a PSA anybody in
his age was that because his risk of
dying from prostate cancer if he had
made it to 85 is so so low that we
generally recommend people over 75 not
to make PSA screening anymore okay so
and drinking water is not good it's not
healthy for your prostate gland it
doesn't affect it may be healthy for
other things but it's not good for your
prostate and not good to lower your PSA
anyway okay and can you do anything good
for your prostate to prevent getting
cancer well we're not sure I mean if if
you have a kind of a healthy lifestyle
from the time you're a boy and you eat
the right things like more legends more
fruits not too much meat not too much
red meat that may be helpful in reducing
the risk however these data are are not
so sorry I'm going to a healthy
lifestyle that's not good there's
another thanks so much for being with us
didn't good shape thank you okay
you